do less of what you like and more of
what you love that's one of the keys to
Mastery like I like three hours of
Netflix but dude I love holding a
finished book in my hand people who are
living with purpose are scientifically
happier they're scientifically more
connected to relationships so a lot of
this is going okay I need a purpose I
always tell people you have access to
time machines they're called mentors I'm
the CEO of my actions not the CEO of my
outcomes welcome back to the think media
podcast today our special guest John
Acuff is going to be breaking down some
tips for
2024 we're going to be learning some
science-backed principles for making
2024 your best year we're going to
discover some of the mistakes people
make with goals that keep them stuck
we're also going to learn some insights
from John on how he's built a globally
influential brand using content and if
you're just meeting John he's the
bestselling author of nine books already
working on his 10th Inc top 100
leadership speakers he has spoken for
companies like FedEx Range Rover
Microsoft Nokia and Comedy Central based
in Nashville with his wife and two
daughters and check out the show notes
because this is not John's first time on
the podcast and he always drops value
but welcome back for this episode John
how's it going it's great to see you
again Sean I love getting to hang out
with you I love hanging out with you
we're going to be diving into goal
setting it's a perfect time of the year
to be doing that but anytime it's always
a good doesn't have to be January 1st
doesn't have to be New Year's always a
good time to get locked in with your
goals but before we kind of unpack some
things I'm looking for a quick tip what
is one quick tip for being more
effective in 2024 well uh one quick tip
would be write it down I think it's a
good a good filter of if you're going to
actually do something is if you'll take
two minutes to write it down so if you
tell me I've got a bunch of goals and I
go I'd love to see the list and you go I
don't have a list like a lot of them are
in my head I'll go I don't think you're
going to do them so do the easy thing of
write it down a lot of people don't do
do that and then they keep a goal in
their head and they forget the goal so I
touch my goals a thousand times a year
they're not in a drawer they're on my
wall they're on my phone they're I have
a lot of different places I've written
them down so just a simple action can be
write it down like it's easier to get
your goals done when you've actually
written them down and when you say you
touch your goals do you mean like Ted
lasso has the team jump up and hit the
Bel sign dude I do everything I like I'm
the guy now like I'm a very cynical at
sarcastic guy but I'm willing to try
anything when it comes to a goal to see
if it works and so I used to make fun of
people that would have like a positive
note on their bathroom mirror and now
I'm like no that that actually turns out
every High performer I talk to if you
get them off the mic and go hey you
doing anything that's like maybe a
little unusual they all have things
they're doing they just a lot of times
don't talk about them so no yeah I'm
like I don't care if it's a t-shirt I'm
wearing like here's the thing Sean I'll
give you one example this there was a
study done by NYU where they took two
groups of college students one group
they said here's a bunch of words make
some sentences the next group they gave
the same instruction but their words
they had hidden words in there related
to being old retired bald slow Florida
and so then after half an hour they go
we want you to walk down the hall and
take the other part of the test and
that's when the real test started CU
they secretly timed the students as they
walked and the students who had read the
words about being old physically walked
slower just reading words about being
old made them annoyingly at Gold so my
interpretation of that which is
interesting is when you have like I saw
somebody the other day had on their
nightstand a sign that said I can't
adult today can you imagine what that
does to you like if you wear a shirt
that says I'm sorry I'm late I didn't
want to come I can't adult today you're
telling yourself a hundred times you
can't perform you're not good we have a
whole series of depression and sadness
wear at department stores that say
you're inadequate you should stay
inadequate don't try and I'm the
opposite I'm like nah I'm going to like
I need a lot of notes I need a lot of
techniques but I think culturally we're
in a spot where people have really
accepted um average and we haven't
recognized it's being marketed to us so
write it down and then do all kinds of
things to reinforce it touch your goals
a thousand times a year we're going to
be diving into insights from your new
book all it takes is a goal but I
actually want to go high level what are
your predictions for
2024 as specifically a content creator
podcaster putting your video podcast on
YouTube and generally thinking about
you're in the info business education
business you coach leaders and a lot of
people listening to this are in that
same vantage point so as you think about
we we talked back during covid that
disrupted your business um took all of
your on the road speaking engagements
had you at home you're always of course
going to be looking at the landscape for
you what are maybe whatever you would
want to answer the question predictions
positioning moves you're making Hedges
you're making risks you're taking 2024
John Acuff that that's a great question
um I would say one thing I'm doing is
I'm getting around wise people um I
always tell people you have access to
time machines they're called mentors
they've been to the Future you're trying
to get to and we'll tell you about it if
you ask and so I'm deliberately carving
out more and more time to get around
people that I go wow they've got the
kind of life I want to have in 12 years
I want to end up there what did they do
so I'm I'm adding more time for real
relationships um the second thing is I'm
paying attention to price I'm really
paying attention to price because for
the last few years there's been free
money in the marketplace there's been
money just given out and now I don't
think we're talking enough about how
hard it is for the average person
financially and so I'm trying to be
really deliberate about how am I pricing
things what am I seeing for my audience
what are they teaching me about their
price what do they have that's available
for you know investment how do I make
sure that I'm 10x 20x in what it's worth
to them I think a lot of creators get
into the spot of how big could I make
the price versus going how big could I
make the value so I'm going when it's a
tough economy when it's a recession when
it's inflation whatever word you want to
use how do I add extra value um and then
I'm looking for um I'm looking for money
in places where I feel really qualified
so I'm going okay anyone on the planet
can tomorrow go I'm now an expert in
this and I'll tell that on Instagram the
average person can't get a company to
book them to speak at their keynote
because they've never heard of them they
don't have history so I'm going okay
instead of getting distracted by some of
the shiny stuff where do I lean into
this um and then I heard something
yesterday a sales technique that it's
just it's just blowing my mind I had a
friend say hey don't offer three options
when you off when you add the third it
becomes a thinking decision when it's
two it's a choice it's either or when
you add the third somebody goes well I
got to analyze these I got to figure
this out and he said look salt and
pepper and we are at a restaurant he
goes salt and pepper which one do you
want when you have two options it's a
choice when I add hot sauce and
mayonnaise and mustard and relish you go
oh I got to you know what let me get
back to you because I got to really and
so simplifying my message simplifying
what I'm offering figuring out real pain
points I'm trying to put a bigger focus
on what people really need and the pain
points they're going through um versus
you know trying to go okay I think this
is what people want like spending more
time going what do they really need and
then what do I have that fixes that
brilliant let's dive into goal setting
all kinds of tactical details we can get
into but at the start of your new book
you actually say I didn't think about
living up to my full potential until I
was about 45 years old research showed
that 96% of people feel like they're not
living up to their full potential and
you're saying be the 4% take us back to
what was going through your mind when
you were
45 and this idea of us reaching our
potential yeah it was regret that was
going through my mind we were at a
college campus I went to Sanford
University in Burmingham Alabama I was
standing next to my wife who went there
too and our oldest daughter was touring
it as a potential student and my wife
said wasn't College amazing wasn't it
the best and I was having the opposite
experience I was saying no it was a it
was a train wreck I moved from
Massachusetts to Alabama and nobody said
hey by the way culturally it's going to
be a little different Massachusetts
different from Alabama and I came in
with a chip on my shoulder I got
rejected for everyy Fraternity I got put
on social suspension for a year for a
Halloween prank I'd love to say I turned
it around but I never did senior year I
was really into Raves so if right now
you're like oh like dancing with glow
sticks and reflective clothing and
warehouses yeah exactly that's a pretty
good description and so I was standing
that moment going look at the potential
I wasted look what I could have done if
I had known what I known now and so I
drove home to Nashville and I had this
sense of regret but I had recently
written a book called soundtracks about
changing your thought patterns and so I
knew I get to choose what I think and so
I said how can I instead of sitting in
this regret what would be a positive
version of this what what could I do and
I realize those are four years and I
can't change those but I might have 40
more on tap what could I do going
forward and that's what started it I
Sean i' tell you and anyone watching
this especially if you're a content
creator there's three things you should
look for when you create something new
one you look for a personal connection
you look for a heart connection with
yourself the second thing is a need do
people need it your audience your
neighbors do they need it the third is
there a spot for you in the marketplace
can you find a spot if you get all three
of those you're going to create
something that people absolutely love so
I had the personal connection I did the
study and asked 3,000 people if they
feel like they're living up their
potential they weren't and then I
checked the marketplace and a lot of
books about potential are fuzzy and
holistic and high level and I'm a what
do I do with this on a Tuesday kind of
guy like if I see a keynote I'm like
great great that's inspiring I want to
be inspired what do I actually do with
this that's why you and I get along so
well is that you don't just go YouTube's
great YouTube's it's the future like you
say here's the camera here's the
technique here's what we did nine years
ago here's what we're doing like you're
a tactical guy too so once I had those
three things then I was like okay I
think I can figure this out and I'm
willing to spend years doing it and then
talk about it for another 10 years well
I know here at the think media podcast
we want to be in the 4% that are living
up to our full potential and goals can
help us get there but before we go
forward don't you recommend that we look
back tell us a little bit about the
vision wall and the rear view mirror
before ultimately looking forward and
setting goals yeah so when you realize
you want to live into your potential you
run into what I call the vision wall
which is you have to know the next 10
years before you take the first step and
part of that has happened we've
misinterpreted great books like Steven
Cub's seven habits um where he says
begin with the end in mind we've
misinterpreted that into I need to know
the end before I begin you've had people
say to you Sean I'd love to do a channel
but I don't know my perfect Niche I
can't do a single video Until I've got
my Niche dialed in and you go whoa whoa
whoa do a 100 you'll figure your Niche
out as you go like we say Niche to get
rich which is like saying Sean what's
your favorite ride at Disney and if you
said I I've never been i' go I know but
you have to pick your favorite ride
before you've tried it can you imagine
if you said to Shawn on day one of
YouTube you have to know exactly what
you'll be doing 10 years later 12 years
later like you couldn't have possibly so
you run into this Vision wall and my
version of fixing that was I can't look
forward because it's overwhelming it's
intimidating I feel stuck in the present
what if I looked back which everybody
tells you not to do they say Don't Look
Back you're not going that direction but
you have this Rich Real History to learn
from so all I did was I took a piece of
paper and wrote best moments on the top
of it in the Augusta Georgia airport and
I started to list out things that lit me
up things that gave me joy things where
I felt in flow things where I felt like
I was living out of my purpose and it
started out with 10 15 20 and ended up
being 171 different things and I learned
self-awareness I learned gratitude I
taught it to hundreds of people this
exercise and Sean there's a magical
moment that happens for every single
person you automatically go I want more
of that you see it from your past and go
I want more of that in my future and
that's where the whole thing shifts into
a life plan
and you go how do I do that on purpose
and then that's where a goal goes I I
got you I'm the vehicle to that let's
let's do it and then you get this really
fun life that's based in fact and based
in you versus based in who do I want to
be in 30 years which is an impossible
question to answer so to dial in on that
that is the best moments list
exercise yep and so and break that down
again like so what exactly do I do if
I'm going to do the best moments list
exercise I'm pausing this podcast I'm
pulling out a journal right now I'm
setting a timer to do this a little bit
later so I can actually take action on
this episode what is the best moments
list so I'll give you a couple prompts
because I never go I never go to a blank
piece of paper by myself it's too
overwhelming like I don't believe in
writer block I believe in idea
bankruptcy like if you can't write it
just means you haven't been collecting
enough ideas I always bring friends to
the blank piece of paper I never go
alone so here's a couple prompts one
would be what's something I do where
time speeds up or slows down like what's
an activity time speeds up or slows down
here's another one um if I had to list
out my best accomplishments what would I
say and no false humility in this we
need you like this is your chance the
internet tells you humble brag humble
brag the interet internet's okay with
your sadness it doesn't like your
celebration so I need you to say like no
I do this thing really well what's the
best job I ever had or what's the best
part of a job I ever had um what
inspires me what would I do for free
like you come up with a bunch of prompts
and they're small things and big things
so today Sean I ran um four miles and
when I was running my brother called me
and he's one of the few people on the
planet that will have a conversation
with me while I'm running he doesn't
care how loud it is he's a runner twoo
that man that was the best moment for me
today that was the best moment there's
other ones that are big hitting the New
York Times with sellers list that was
big um opening a new notebook like when
I get a fresh notebook and it hasn't
been written yet that's the best moment
so you write down those and you give
your head and your heart some time to do
it cuz it's going to be challenging at
first because your head and your heart
are so used to finding your worst
moments and culturally we're addicted to
trauma and sadness right now and we talk
about that more than Joy like for every
100 scientific studies on sadness
there's only one written on Joy we as a
culture have ricocheted from not feeling
at all to all you can feel is sadness
and joy and so it'll take a little while
because it's counterintuitive but you
just create this big list and then where
it gets really fun is you'll recognize
every one of your moments fits in one of
four things one of four categories
experience accomplishment relationship
and object and I'll give you a metaphor
if you go on a hike like say you hike
some trail in Vegas because you love
Vegas and it's beautiful and you're by
yourself that's an experience if you go
say you go with Ryan pan and you get to
encourage each other and you pour into
him and he pours into you that's a
relationship moment the the person made
the moment if you hike it faster than
you've ever hiked it because you track
it on Garmin and or straa that's an
accomplishment if you picked up a pine
cone because you wanted to remember that
moment that's an object so what happens
is I have people categorize the list so
the first thing is come up with the list
second thing just categorize was that
relationship why did I put that on there
was it people was that accomplishment
and then all of a sudden people go wow I
didn't realize 60% of my list was
accomplishment I grew up in a house
where accomplishments were supposed to
be downplayed like my parents didn't
like us to like I didn't want to
outshine my brother whatever I didn't
know I was an accomplishment person this
list has taught me or wow 80% was a
relationship ship I've been isolated for
3 years with Co no wonder I'm in a funk
my heart when I ask my heart what are
the best things that happened me the
last 10 years 80% or accomplishment or
relationship no wonder and so once you
have that then you go okay I'm going to
figure out going forward how do I get
more relationships or how do I be
deliberate about accomplishments or how
do I make sure that I'm in a community
so it becomes this really honest
personality test that gives you the path
forward man such a tactical exercise we
can look in our rear view mirrror and
Look Backwards to really prepare to
launch forwards as we set goals before
we get into some technical goal setting
I'm curious your take on the power of
goals I mean I think we all know setting
goals is incredibly powerful apparently
in 2013 Tom Holland said he'd like to
play Spider-Man down the line and he
specifically said in 10 years time so he
set a goal he declared it but it ended
up actually coming sooner Jennifer Lopez
at the beginning of her acting career
had a goal to star in Ro romantic
comedies um but because she was Puerto
Rican Latina and she saw that it was
really all white women in romantic
comedies at the time she set out and set
a goal and ultimately went on to be a
star in many box office romc uh notably
21 2001's The Wedding Planner so we have
seen this across the board of the power
of goals go high level with me of of
really what's waiting for us on the
other side of goals the why of taking
the time to do it and what you've
discovered well I mean you're you're
designed for it um I you know let's just
talk to the men for a minute uh a man um
without a mission doesn't stop fighting
he just turns the battle Inward and
starts fighting himself and the people
in his and his and his loved ones like
you're meant to have a purpose people
who are living with purpose are
scientifically happier they're
scientifically more connected to
relationship so a lot of this is going
okay I need a purpose like I know like
I've had probably five or six men in my
circle who in their mid-40s lose a job
or something happens and they never kind
of get it back and it's watching a slow
train wreck and everybody listening to
this right now or watching this has a
friend who's in the same position like
one of the hardest things um in life is
watching someone you love make life
harder than it needs to be and so a goal
is that path and so I'll just give you
my version of it in my own life I'm 34 I
have two kids under the age of four I've
hit a career ceiling there's nowhere
else to go I'm a senior content designer
there's no super duper senior content
designer I don't want to manage people
and be a creative director I'm stuck I
make very little money um we have I have
an hour commute each way in Atlanta no
time and people change by one or two
ways involuntary crisis something
disastrous happens divorce Health crisis
they lose their job or a voluntary trick
you trick yourself out of the comfort
zone you get a taste of something and go
I want more of that like like you did
that that happened to you with YouTube
like you figure like oh I want more of
that that wasn't your path you worked at
a church dude like there is no you
there's not 50 Sean canels that are like
oh the classic YouTube Empire path that
all people who work at churches take
like so for me no one changes just
because no one ever wakes up and goes
I'm going to be more disciplined I'm
going to have more willpower I'm going
to have more sacrifice persistence what
happens is you often get a taste of
something you want more and then you
start to pursue it so I started blogging
a little bit just on a whim not with a
not with a plan and I thought wow this
this makes me like I feel really engaged
I feel there's a whole world of people
that's what happens to everybody on
YouTube and so I didn't decide to get up
early because I was disciplined I
decided to get up early because man I
got to blog more and the joy was deep
and rich and full I didn't stop watching
as much TV because I was disciplined it
just wasn't as fulfilling as blogging
and so what happens is when you discover
a goal you care about your time becomes
like a log and you want to throw as many
logs into the fire as you can to make
the blaze as big and as bright and that
person is alive like that's where people
start going what are you doing like the
first couple months people will
eventually go what are you doing
eventually they go will you show me how
to do what you're doing that's your
story dude like you had that thing where
people it switched from I'm doing it I'm
doing it I'm doing it and it always
starts yourself it always leades a
service what happened for you you like I
think I could teach other people how to
tap in you found a fountain of youth
that Lit you up and so that's why you do
a goal like you do a goal because you're
designed to do goals it makes you come
alive it helps it's contagious like
that's the thing I worked for Dave
Ramsey for three years dude we would
have people come up at events and go man
Dave Ramsey saved my marriage and we'd
be like what like he didn't write a
marriage book but when you work on your
finances guess what your marriage
improves when you work on your health
guess what your finances approved like
Joy is contagious discipline's
contagious goals are contagious so like
if you said why should we work on goals
because it changes every part of your
life and it's hard to see that at the
beginning it can be overwhelming at the
beginning but I would never tell you
that at the beginning like the last
thing I'd say about this I did a book
signing with John Maxwell once like 15
years ago I did 15 minutes on stage he
did 45 and then they put us next to each
other in a Lobby to do a book signing
and there were 200 people in his line
and there was nobody in my line a s
there wasn't a single person who came
over to buy my book that was very
humbling disheartening all the words
that mean super sad and a dude patted me
on the back the stranger and said hey 10
Years buddy 10 years and that was
accurate but discouraging because he was
right it was going to take me 10 years
more of being disciplined all the things
but it was discouraging because I
couldn't I couldn't handle the decade
promise in that moment I just needed to
do the next day so what I tell you is
try a goal do the next day I think
you'll get a month in a year in a decade
in and be thrilled you did um but I
wouldn't say you got to start with the
decade first I'd say what if you just
start with the day let's just start with
today you break down goals into three
categories easy goals middle goals
guaranteed goals so now if we understand
the power of goals we want to get
started why different categories and how
can these be helpful well you got to
think about it like a ladder Sean if
somebody say you were going to clean
your leaves out of your Gutter and a
neighbor let you borrow the ladder and
they brought it over and it only had one
rung on the bottom and rung on one Rong
at the top and was just empty in between
they said here you go here's the ladder
you go this is use I can't do anything
with this that's what most people do so
they go day one and then I want to have
a million YouTube subscribers I want to
plaque so I don't have any steps in
between I have no rungs and you go how
are you going to get up there and they
go I'm just going to believe I'm going
to believe in myself and my thing is
what if we took easy goals middle goals
guaranteed goals and built a lot of
rungs on that goal ladder like if we had
a rung every 6 in would that be an
easier ladder to climb like I think it I
think it would would that be an easier
ladder for you to get to the top of I
think it would and so I'll give you a
specific YouTube example you you know
you do your first couple videos that's
an easy goal like you don't you don't
overcommit you don't say I'm going to do
I know people say the same thing they
say to me they like they go man I'm
going to do 10 videos a day or like I'm
going to do a video and you go how many
did you do last month they go none but
going forward like Sean I'm serious I'm
gonna do three a day for the next year
and you go man I don't that's going to
be really hard to maintain the quality
the pace like I just what if you did
like one a week for four weeks and then
the second four-week cycle you did two a
week and then the third week cycle you
did three a week and you build up that's
what it's like to do an easy goal that
gets to a middle goal and then gets to a
guaranteed goal it's just about your
time commitment the effort you're making
the in investment you're making as you
climb the ladder and once you get to the
middle of the ladder and those middle
goals you can see some big crazy goals
that aren't aren't impossible like I'm
going to sell a million books in my
career but I didn't say that on day one
I I said that a couple books in and I
was like I think I can do this I think I
can do this like it might take me longer
than I want but like I'm already in the
middle of the ladder what's going to
stop me from climbing like I'm going to
keep climbing like you're not going to
stop making YouTube videos like for you
to go like it's going to be 10 million
20 million 30 million that's not
impossible that's a guarantee at this
point so that's what I mean by the three
types of goals and there's specific
things related to each but in a general
sense it's about building that ladder
and then climbing to the top I'm curious
uh one of the things we encourage our
listeners is the difference between
results goals and action goals a results
goal being I want to get my first a
th000
subscribers which there's so many
practical steps you can take but the
timeline on that could vary um it might
be a week for one person it might be a
year for another but an action goal I'm
going to post a video a week is not
based on results externally it's 100%
based on just your ability to execute do
you have a way of articulating that and
explaining which one is both powerful
and when you write your goals do you
have both do you have sort of actions
but also the dream result amount of
books sold amount of followers grow grow
my channel this much this year how do
you differentiate between those yeah so
I love that this the soundtrack and
everybody should just write this down on
a poster note is I'm the CEO of my
actions not the CEO of my outcomes
I am the CEO of my actions not the CEO
of my outcomes so I know that to be true
like I didn't you mentioned earlier that
Co wrecked my speaking it was the best
year I had ever lined up I had the
events were booked it wasn't theoretical
like it was booked I drove home I did
comedy opening up for Dolly Parton at
the Ryman in Nashville and I drove home
that night and I said to myself this is
only February the rest of the year is
going to be amazing and it was like the
narrator was like it was not in fact to
be amazing at all and so I didn't
control that so what I did control was
doing a podcast was fil filming you know
virtual events whatever so I love
action-based goals um what I found is I
like to have a mix of both depending on
the goal so I you know it's funny
Anthony O'Neal is a big YouTuber that I
like he's a sharp dude and we were
talking about this on his on his channel
he said you know John I set a goal to
have a million subscribers by a certain
date and we're going to miss the date
and I said well that just is going to
mean it's 3 months sweeter like that's
your reframe if it takes me 3 months
longer dude it's three months sweeter
the story just got three months better
like instead of going and I hustled for
a year you go dude I hustled for 18
months like that sentence hits hard dude
you have to reframe it that way so with
me I go say my running goal like I want
to run I want to move my body a th000
miles a year that's that's a a pretty
General goal for me which usually means
about 650 running 350 walking so that's
a big results goal but my weekly action
goal is I want to work out five times a
week so that's a weekly action I can get
excited about I don't get excited about
the big number that much cuz it feels
far away dude in January when you've
done like 42 and you look at a th that's
discouraging so I always say look at the
thing that lights you up look at the
goal measurement that fires you up and
if finishing your video that week fired
you up awesome you went one for one on
that week like lean into that and then
once you get to a spot where you're like
no the result the big result like oh
that's going to be fun that's going to
be fun I can't wait to do that so I
usually do a mix of them but I start
people with the action because I want
you to start with the thing you can
control I want you to start with the
thing you can kind of lean into and go
this is on me because a big part of goal
Sean is learning to take personal
responsibility learning like one of the
phrases I say is I am the CEO of me and
I'm the best boss I'm the CEO of me and
I'm the best boss because I'm constantly
tempted to blame other people like I got
that blame that blame bug in me and I'm
constantly tempted to do that and I want
to go no no no no no so like an example
that I sometimes when I'm trying to hide
from difficult work will blame my
schedule so what I'll do is I'll
overfill my schedule so I don't have
time to write the book because a book is
hard to write and so I'll hide from the
book out of fear by overfilling my
schedule and then I get to blame the
schedule then I get to go man I'd be
crushing this YouTube channel if I
wasn't so busy I got all these other
things and now it's not my fault I'm a
victim of the calendar and then you go
wait a second what if I admitted the
responsibility I have admitted the
ability I have and I and I did a little
bit more planning and admit it I'm
afraid and then do something different
so I'm always trying to get people to
take responsibility and actions are
something you control hey we're about to
get back into the podcast in just a
second but I have a question for you do
you want to grow your personal brand
this year do you need more leads and
sales in your business if the answer is
yes then right now is the best time to
go all in on YouTube Today's podcast is
brought to you by think masterclass.com
where you can get OnDemand access to a
1hour deep dive training revealing how
to start and grow a profitable YouTube
channel this year for a limited time you
can get access to this ond demand class
entirely for free where you will learn
the three biggest mistakes that people
make when starting a YouTube channnel
the new rules and changes that have been
happening on YouTube and how you can use
them to create an unfair advantage and
the exact strategy we use at think media
to generate over
350,000 organic views every single day
the data is clear 70% of viewers claim
that YouTube makes them more aware of
new brands so don't wait any longer to
start growing your brand and business
with YouTube just go to think
masterclass.com to get access to this no
fluff highly tactical free ond demand
training that's think masterclass.com
brilliant um your mentality towards goal
setting of course is revealing the power
the potential of it how much it can
change our lives but I want to kind of
set up a challenge and see how you would
respond John Acuff versus Adam Grant
because yeah he actually highlighted a
problem with the practice of goal
setting
and he said that when you fall short of
an objective disappointment can send you
spiraling in Troublesome ways and
reearch backs that up and that when you
set goals in the first place it can
actually limit you so as a Wharton
organizational psychologist Adam Grant
says that sometimes when you set a goal
it creates tunnel vision and it blinds
you to Alternative goals and so in light
of this what what would you say to some
of the objections and challenges with
goal setting specifically some of the
points that Adam made yeah well I mean
one he's wicked smart I mean I grew up
in Massachusetts that means very if you
didn't grow up in Massachusetts yeah
he's brilliant so it's hard for me to
argue with specifics of what he said
what I would say is um I think it
depends on the person I always think
like sometimes people say to me they go
I don't like goals and I'll go what do
you like instead they'll go I like
intentions I go what's an intention they
go you figure out three things you want
to do and then you hold yourself
accountable I go that sounds a lot like
a goal or they'll go I don't like goals
I like habits I don't care what word you
use if you get the thing done like I
really I really don't so for me um as
far as like does it limit you um I guess
in how you said it I would 100% agree
with him that um there's right ways to
set goals and there's wrong ways so you
know I don't like any brush where I go
oh goals goals are bad or goals are good
I think that they can be both I think
that people can be compulsive about
beautiful things one of the reasons I
don't run marathons is I'm a very
compulsive person and I can do half
marathons cuz that fits my life it fits
my training schedule if I open the door
to full marathons I will train until I
can't run anymore like I will not stop I
know myself like so I would never say
marathons are bad a lot of people love
them and can do them and aren't
compulsive like me my wife is like dude
you would be up at 3 a.m. you would be
obnoxious you would be in ultramarathons
you would be in the woods for 100 miles
like I know that's where youd go so
knowing my personality I'm like nah dude
half marathon Is My Jam so like as far
as do goals hold people back or limit
how they do I could totally see that if
you do them the wrong way um and then
the other thing is the disappointment so
part of the joy of an easy goal is the
disappointment is so small so what
happens in my opinion it's really weird
to set a New Year's resolution because
often you're trying to do something you
haven't done for 365 days like yeah
you're going to be disappointed like
that's that's instant failure and or the
other fear is people go I don't want to
pick the wrong thing we're afraid of
what cvy said putting the ladder against
the wrong wall getting to the top of the
ladder and go oh this is the wrong wall
but that's why I say try it for seven
days if you try if I get you to try
something half an hour a day for seven
days and after three and a half hours
you go yeah wasn't my jam awesome dude
we just eliminated a goal that wasn't
going to serve you let's do a different
one you're not crushed after those seven
days you go I can't believe that instead
of scrolling Instagram I was on a go I
worked on a goal for three and a half
days like I'm devastated I'd much rather
you try it an experiment so I think one
of the ways you get around that thing
Adam's saying is a concern is speed
dating like speed date goals dude try a
bunch of goals let a winner step to the
Forefront if you approach goals from a
marriage only perspective you will be
disappointed how do you deal with
opportunity overwhelm um two sides to
that one for some they're trying to to
get into success that could lead to
opportunity overwhelm so I don't
necessarily mean too many invites or too
much money or something like this but I
think there's two categories there's the
one of everybody listening to this right
now is being inundated with the
opportunity to read a lot of good books
and follow a lot of Frameworks the
opportunity to build their brand on a
lot of platforms the opportunity to
cover a lot of different topics the
opportunity to start a lot of side
hustles let me Chase AI right now let me
Chase Amazon let me Chase YouTube um let
me Chase this event or that event or
this network and it's only getting worse
it's not getting better there's so much
opportunity and then also with more
success or just more growth as the
prophet and philosopher notorious b said
you know mo More Money More Problems
like you just you start having more
opportunity coming your way so do you
have like an opportunity framework that
you use um that could also be helpful
for us yeah so I'll give you a couple
things one again put this soundtrack on
a Post-It note my imagination is bigger
than my calendar like that's why you
feel overwhelmed it will always feel
that way dude your imagination is
endless it is bottomless we've had the
same calendar for the last 700 years so
and then you add it to other people's
imaginations and then you add it to
tools like YouTube and then you add it
to chat GPT like you should that's not a
bad thing like I tell my co like we have
a a go Community called the guaranteed
go communities I always tell them we're
too many people yeah we're too many
people we're always going to have too
many things that's not failure that's a
sign you're alive I love people that
have too many things that have like I
those are my people I where I messed up
over the last five years probably Sean
is I used to teach people how to
brainstorm goals and that was a huge
mistake and here's what it was a mistake
because they already had to many and so
imagine you feel overwhelmed and you
come to me and I go hey you know how you
feel overwhelmed what if we add it 100
new goals I surveyed my audience the
average person had 22.8 goals 22.8 you
ever try to juggle 22 balls at a time
it's very challenging so one take the
sting of disappointment or surprise out
of it you're going to have too many just
accept that there's not going to be less
a year from now dude there's going to be
some hologram platform that you're like
dude we tested it I think we tested it I
don't know man like it's only going to
get more intense and so I think as far
as like I wish I had a perfect framework
that was really clear but what I would
say is that I think you have to review
what you're doing in regular intervals
to make sure you're still on the right
thing so what I like I don't want you to
review at the end of the year and go man
I spent a lot of time on something that
didn't matter I'd much rather you go
it's the end of the week okay am I still
in my zone it's the end of the month am
I still in my zone um and so what that
looks like for me also is like there's
some things I do that are B+ one of the
things I push back against that so many
people say how you do anything is how
you do everything that's not true how I
treat the neighborhood kids is very
different than how I treat my own kids
it is it's very different like how I
rake my yard is different than how I
write books it takes me a thousand hours
to write a book it's such a like
perfectionistic thing the reality is
Sean if you're going to be busy some
things are going to get B+ and they
deserve it like my podcast I know if I
spent 40 hours a week on it it would be
better it would it would be better but I
know that I've carved out a really
special public speaking career that I
love that few people get access to and I
I value that and I treasure that my
clients my speaking clients deserve A+
my books deserve A+ my podcast I do the
best with the amount of time it deserves
but if I spent 40 hours a week on it I
would go out of business pretty quickly
because I'd have to start phoning in
other things that actually mattered so
part of what you have to do with
opportunity cost is go which of these
things have the Roi that I need which of
these things deserve my time can I
retire some also you should retire stuff
like you should get out of stuff like
the way I look at it is if you don't
enjoy it you're not good at it and it
doesn't make money that is the trifecta
of things you should quit it's one thing
if you enjoy it and you suck at it
you'll get better at it you'll have the
passion it's another thing if you hate
it you're terrible at it and it doesn't
make you money like that's where and so
the other the last thing I'd say
opportunity cost is often um put to bed
by data and like what I say the phrase I
say is data kills denial which prevents
disaster so I would dare you to look at
data and go okay I got 50 things I can
do let me look at the data now the
problem is Sean we don't understand that
some of the people we look up to have
massive teams let's just pick one one
person that we both admire and respect
and love and he spoke at your event Gary
Vee I meet people who compare themselves
to Gary Vee he has like 900 employees so
the next time you do that imagine you're
driving past a ninstory corporate
building and you go that's who I'm
competing with I just got to do as well
as that building you would never do that
you would never go I'm up against 900
full-time staff but when you see a video
online and you go that dude's everywhere
he's doing so much you don't give
yourself credit he has a nine like if
you played basketball against 900 people
would you score a single point of course
not but we forget that and Gary's not
even saying that he's very open about I
have a big team it's not that it's just
we misinterpret it so that's the other
thing about opportunity cost look at the
data this thing's not making me money
and it's costing me a ton of time just
the other day this is so funny you ask
this question the pro and this drives me
nuts people go John you're leaving money
on the table you're leaving money on the
table and they'll point out something
they'll go it's really easy it's easy
you should just do it and they act like
there's a million dollars on the table
that I just need to reach my hand out
and then and and I could just grab it
like there's no effort no and so
somebody there was a product I won't say
which product cuz we're still talking
about it and they were like we should do
this product we should do this product
and they were like so and so does it and
they've sold a million and so I knew I
knew somebody on so and so's team and so
I go hey how many people work on that
product I'm just curious they go 12
people full-time I go okay okay okay
cool cool and then I went back to the
person I was like dude we have nobody in
that department on that product we'd
have to staff up 12 full-time people
don't say it's easy just because it
seems easy the data once I had some data
though dude like here's it here's the LA
this is my last data trick somebody was
like dude you should do a live event
like and you've done a live event it
worked really well somebody was like hey
you should do a live event where it's
just you it's in our town and here's the
numbers I ran the numbers and I would
have to charge because I don't have
sponsorship relationships right now like
the way I do my stuff isn't doesn't have
a ton of sponsorships I would have to
charge $1,500 a ticket for for this
event to be profitable and then I did a
price comparison and like Global
Leadership Summit was like 250 and they
have like Bob Iger and like all the and
I was like I'm just going to be six
times their price with just me and like
that then it'll and I was like no the
numbers will I do an event someday yeah
I probably will when I can figure out
the numbers but what I see is when
people don't look at the numbers and
they go I'm just going to believe in the
best and like they act like math I mean
but dude that's just human nature people
don't go to the doctor when they feel
sick because they don't want to find out
they're sick so they just get sicker
because they don't want to look at the
data so like the faster you can make
friends with the data the better you can
make better decisions and then you can
actually build something that has a ton
of opportunities that was like I can't
wait to see you try to cut these into
like 60c Clips or Instagram because
these are I'm just like ah but I think
it'll be fun that one was fire I'm glad
to get you triggered and I actually was
having kind of like a a vision of you in
the future as you were talking you're
such a Wordsmith and you're already at
like this place of being so sharp with
your words and quotes and phrases but I
feel like sometime in the future many
people will travel from around the world
to walk up like 200 flights of stairs
and you'll just be sitting at the top
with I don't know if you're a pet guy
like a cat or like a dog next to you and
you'll just and you'll and you'll just
be like dispensing wisdom and somebody
will come to ask you a question about
life and you'll be like well here's the
soundtrack for that you know and you
just drop it so you're developing that
now but I'm like that look like in 10 to
20 years I've got the gray hair but dude
it's going to take me 10 more 10 more
years you're right it's going to take
some time and then you have to figure
out the location I don't know if there's
any like you know pyramids in Nashville
that people could I just build a
staircase it won't even be connected to
a building it'll just be stairs off into
space and they'll be like you ever go up
those space stairs John aob Phil in the
middle of the in the middle of middle
Tennessee like whatever problem you have
if you can endure the climb you will
it'll pay off with wisdom at the top so
you you know it's actually um I'm
curious your thoughts on visualization
as it relates to goal setting picturing
your future both Arnold Schwarzenegger
and Jim Carrey have referenced a lot to
visualization uh when Arnold
Schwarzenegger won Mr Universe uh he
said before he won it he walked around
the tournament acting like he owned it
and saying the title was already mine
and he said he had won it so many times
in his mind there was no doubt that he
could win it he did the same thing in
movies he visualized himself becoming a
famous actor earning big money he could
feel and taste success and he knew it
would happen and Carrie was Jim Carrey
acknowledged for picturing himself as
Rich famous and successful before it
happened and when Oprah Winfrey was
interviewing him he said he would drive
around Los Angeles visualizing things
coming to him that he wanted he had
nothing but time and he said but it did
make him feel better he would drive and
think I do have those things are out
there and he wrote himself a check for
$10 million again dreaming of the money
that would come his way and he dated
that Thanksgiving 1995 and right before
the actual Thanksgiving 1995 he found
out he was going to make $10 million on
a film project is this woow woo or is
there something actual true to these
actions in this visualization stuff yeah
so I used to think it was the dumbest
thing ever because again cynical
sarcastic negative um but then I started
to talk to people I respected who were
further ahead of me on on paths and a
lot of them did a version of this and so
I started to really study it so now I
think there's always parts of this stuff
that heads into the woooo and I'm a
pretty like feet on the ground kind of
dude um and so for me the ver like yes I
believe in the power of visualization
the way I think about it is like doing a
dry run of an event before the event
happens so let's make it really
practical the when I'm on stage at a
speech I've already given that speech
five times like that's the sixth time
like I already know it's going to work
cuz it's already worked whether I've
done it physically cuz sometimes like
I'll rehearse every speech I do I'm in
the clothes I'm walking up I'm pausing
for Laughs I'm in my office nobody's
laughing but I'm getting the timing
right I'm doing like so by the time I
have muscle memory by the time I get up
on stage but there's also that moment
where you're sitting there going okay
yeah man it's going to be fun and then
I'm going to walk over there and then
I'm going to do this so you can practice
that in your mind too so I do both
things and that's just a form of
visualization the other thing I'd say is
there's so much research about having a
picture you're aiming for and so the
picture can be like one of the exercises
I do is okay it's December 31st and I'm
sitting with my neighbor bill because we
work on our goals together and we're on
his porch what do I want to be able to
say what are the numbers I want to be
able to say do I want to be able to say
I did the 650 miles like I ran the do I
want to be able to like what's the kind
of character I want to have this year
like I'm the kind of guy that blank I'm
the kind of guy that and I form and I'll
write out a picture of this is who I'm
going to be on December 31st as I
reflect on the year that I'm about to
enter into and again it's another
exercise for me to go yeah that's who I
want to be because I think it's really
hard to be that person unless you
practice believing you're that person
and so my thing with things that are woo
woo and you and I have the same Faith
like I'm a Christian so like it's not
like I'm getting like like I have a
pretty clear set of things I believe but
I'm I'm willing to test things I think
when I was younger I was faster to
dismiss something without testing it and
now I see that as the ignorance of Youth
so when I would go that doesn't work and
I hadn't tried it that's that's ignorant
like I haven't you know like and if it's
not in dis like if it's not in
disagreement with my faith why wouldn't
I go I'm going to write down the 10
characteristics some might even call
them fruit Sean of uh my life that I
want to be true and I'm going to review
them and I think every time I review
them it'll be easier to do that I'll
give you an example of how this happened
for me so I had a visualization of doing
an event I was going to an event in
California and Marcus Buckingham was one
of the other speakers Marcus Buckingham
strength finder sold millions of books
very successful and I knew in that
moment I'd be insecure I knew in that
moment I'd want to impress him I I'd try
to read my resume I'd try to say New
York Times bestseller whatever it was
I'd feel insecure and I knew that
because I'd done that before I I'd seen
myself like the Catalyst there was a big
event called Catalyst and the Green Room
at Catalyst was my worst nightmare
because I felt so insecure I felt like I
had to connect I had to like I got to
work my way up the popularity ladder
whatever so I said okay I don't want to
do that what could I do instead and I
was like What If instead I figured out
how to honor Marcus Buckingham so I'm
imagining I'm in that Green Room how
could I honor him and I was like oh he's
an author why don't I just read his
latest Book Like No Other speakers read
each other's books what if I just read
his book and when I see him the only
thing I do instead of trying to brag or
show off is ask him questions about his
book and so that's what I did and when I
got there the first thing I said to him
was I think your most recent book is
your most personal book you've ever
written do you agree and that changed
the entire event for me and so now every
morning one of the questions I ask
myself is who can I honor today who can
I bless and I just look through my
calendar I'm visualizing oh I'm going to
be in a real conversation with Shawn
what does it look like for me to honor
him I'm going to be in a real
conversation with the dry cleaner what
does it look like for me to honor them
I'm visualizing that moment so that when
the moment comes up I'm not surprised by
the moment I already had like my brain
goes oh we we've already been through
this moment 10 times let's go and then I
just run that script and it doesn't work
perfectly all the time of course not but
it works a lot better than just
stumbling through my day I want to kind
of go back to something you said and as
we land the plane just talk a little bit
about about putting in the work and this
idea of pursuit of Mastery you've got
New York Times uh bestseller on your
resume nine books out um you're
consistently able to deliver results and
one of the things you mentioned was even
rehearsing your talks and Keynotes you
mentioned being in what you were wearing
pausing for comedic timing you could
speak maybe a little bit to
what you've done in your career to
actually really Step Up in terms of
excellence and I think that sometimes I
would never want our community I don't
think we underestimate the work we
encourage people to put into YouTube or
the effort but sometimes the messaging
gets mixed like hey just start a channel
just lob some videos out there but the
bar is Raising and I kind of want to
relate this to I'm not sure if you heard
but uh Taylor Swift who's making all
these massive headlines broke records
most profitable tour with the AR tour it
was changing economies as far as
restaurants and hotels selling out
pretty dramatic across you know the
country but she actually revealed how
she trained for her 3 and 1 half hour
concert and she actually trained singing
on a treadmill as the actions needed for
a certain song were more difficult she
would increase the incline for fast shut
songs she would uh you know maybe uh go
a little bit faster a fast walk or a jog
and she would sing her entire set on a
treadmill critics I think often times
might say ah you know it's her looks oh
she got lucky oh I don't like Taylor but
sometimes I think people underestimate
the amount of work and hustle that goes
uh behind the scenes and you would love
this Runner's World actually it was all
estimates but Runner's World actually um
thought that she was running for about
they they looked at the set they looked
at the workout she was was doing and it
was about 3 hours and 15 minutes and
about a marathon they they they at about
a 909 Pace that she was running a
marathon every time she did her um arys
tour and so looking at someone 12 gramys
all this other stuff it's easy for
people to be armchair critics not
realizing maybe the price that it cost
to move into greatness levels and
Mastery levels unpack that from your
perspective and maybe encouraging you
know yeah let's set goal
okay yeah I'm telling you to start a
YouTube channel and get committed in
2024 great but what's it really cost to
actually put out great content be great
on YouTube write great books unpack
Mastery for us a little bit Yeah so I'll
give you a phrase that that'll make it
easier do less of what you like and more
of what you love do less of what you
like and more of what you love that's
one of the keys to Mastery I like
Netflix I like like I like three hours
of Netflix but dude I love holding a
finished book in my hand I love love
when I get a foreign addition from like
Greece and I it's a different cover and
somebody in Athens is getting encouraged
by something I wrote in Nashville so I
try to do less of what I like and more
of what I love that helps me with
Mastery because I want to do other stuff
that's distracting or easier or whatever
but for me I'm willing to pay the
long-term price because the long-term
payout is so worth it like it's the ROI
is so good so I think that anyone I
worked with that has a high degree of
Excellence is doing their version of
that Tailor Swift interaction so let me
give you an example um Greg Greg sanki
he's the SEC commissioner probably the
most successful athletic commissioner in
the history of college football he
negotiated the Texas Oklahoma joining
the SEC he led like schools playing
during covid which kind of changed the
whole sporting world one of the nicest
people I've ever met the week that I was
on his podcast or the week that the
Texas and Oklahoma joined the SEC
billion dollar deal he wrote me a
handwritten thank you note for being on
my podcast and I said to my wife isn't
it crazy guys like that still send thank
you notes and she goes no you got it
backwards he's at that level because he
sends thank you notes and so then when I
saw Greg at the SEC um basketball
tournament and I told him about the the
notes he was like oh yeah you mean these
he had a stack of them in his suit coat
pocket during timeouts of the game he
was writing thank you notes cuz he know
knows that's part of his process and so
like I'll give you a music one I went
and saw G Brooks and even if you don't
like country you have to respect what
he's accomplished and like we went and
in the middle of the show Trisha
Yearwood his wife slaps him on the butt
and The Crowd Goes Nuts like ah you know
and I go I wonder if that was planned
and so I I text my buddy and I go hey
you came to G Brooks last night did
Trisha Yearwood slap him on the butt and
he goes yeah totally I go which song and
he says the exact moment and so what I
think happened was they did it once and
it worked and then they made it part of
their plan that's how detailed these
people are that's how dedicated to the
craft they are and so I think that and
you're right that's the part you often
don't see which I try my best to talk
about in a way that's interesting cuz I
don't want it to be discouraging I
really don't want to discourage you that
it's going to take a lot of work like I
want you to get into it and enjoy it
because I think seeing like there's a
magic dude to your first 100 views like
there just is like there's a moment in
YouTube where you go we had people from
Malaysia I don't even I've never I
couldn't find it on a m like and dude
that lights you up there's a moment I
want you to have those moments and then
as you have those and you have enough
joy and momentum then you can kind of go
all right so let's talk about let's
expand the Excellence a little bit
here's what it's going to cost here's
what it's going to do but dude when you
find something that you've got a joy for
that like the another line I say is I
want you to find a goal you love so much
it makes Netflix boring like cuz Netflix
is pretty freaking amazing imagine if
you found something you loved even more
like what and so like I had more 500
a.m. flights um in one week than I did
in 15 years of working for other people
in one week working for myself and my
wife was like if a boss made you work as
hard as you work for yourself you'd be
furious at them and I'm like I know but
I'm still like I love filming videos at
like 3:45 a.m. when I'm headed to the
airport I'm like dude let's go let's go
because the thing I get to do I spend my
entire year to be on stage 50 times for
about an hour so my entire year 365 days
for 50 hours that's a trade I make and
it's worth it it's worth it it's worth
it it's worth it so I always tell people
like find something that even makes the
things you don't like like tolerable I
don't like delayed flights I'm not a
maniac like I'm not going to lie to you
and be like every time I get cancelled
on a flight I go to Milwaukee and I
smiled like no of course not it's
frustrating but if I can quickly go what
did we say at the beginning I touched
the goal a thousand times if I can go no
no remember you get to be on stage like
remember you're going to go get to
encourage a bunch of people remember
that's why you're doing this then the
this doesn't sting as much it's still
challenging I still have to motivate
myself I still have to use tips and
tools and advice and encouragement I
still get down all the stuff but if I
can keep my eyes on that thing um then I
can go oh you're right I going to do the
flight I am going to do the hard work I
am going to do the rehearsal and a
phrase I say to myself all the time is
Excellence is boring Excellence is
boring I used to think when I was
younger it's shiny it's not it's running
in the rain it's thank you notes um that
you will never hear back about it's
putting context into a sales system like
it's you know editing great captions
it's not just like everyone that's into
YouTube knows the parts they love and
they know the parts they hate and
they're like oh this caption I'm not a
writer I'm a performer oh this edit like
it's all those little things all those
little things again and again and again
and again um but it's worth it in the
long run Excellence is boring it's
running on a treadmill and singing for
three hours over and over to build your
endurance six months before the first
show dude like talk about long delayed
gratification she could have done a show
that day and got in a quick dopamine hit
she could have shown up live anywhere
and gone I just want some crowd
adoration I'm gonna perform a couple
songs she said no I'm gonna pay six
months for what's GNA Ripple for years
dude like that's what's really fun to me
about somebody like a Taylor is the
willingness to put off the instant
gratification for the bigger payoff
later we veered off my notes but so many
gems were dropped and I encourage
especially at the timing of this podcast
coming out but of course this is being
watched all times throughout the year
maybe in the future maybe even in
subsequent Years the book is all it
takes as a goal the three-step plan to
ditch regret and tap into your massive
potential uh check it out in the show
notes and one of the best moves you can
make is grab the Audi book and just
start listening on Audible and grab a
journal and start taking action of
course digital physical all the
different things we'll link that up in
the show notes down below we also have a
previous episode with John and his books
are like he just never misses there's
like that consistency to them
soundtracks is another legendary book to
get your mind right your mindset right
even switch up some of your soundtracks
and uh many others and so uh check out
show notes um and then John let us know
though just really want to acknowledge
you for putting so much work in for
making hard things easy for making
complex subjects simple I mean that's a
definition of Mastery and truly
understanding something that
communicating something complex in a
complex way it's not the difficult
challenge taking the complex distilling
it down into all these word Smith
statements is so powerful and so helpful
to us and thank you for adding value to
our community besides the book uh what
else can people check out that we can
link up in the show notes yeah so I
mentioned we have a all-year program
called the guaranteed goals Community
it's just john.com goals and it's kind
of like the Home Depot of goals so it's
a ton of content but it's a lot of
community so I found when it comes to
goals um when somebody's into goals or
curious about goals it's often an
isolating experience cuz nobody in their
immediate Community is either and so
it's hundreds of people from around the
world encouraging each other as they
finish massive goals um that's really
fun then I have a podcast called uh all
it takes is a goal where I talk about
these topics um and obviously it's
something I'm passionate about because I
really believe goals can change your
life and they changed mine and I always
say I'm a late bloomer who discovered
them in the power in the m in my mid-30s
and now I'm trying to help other people
do it a lot faster John Acuff ladies and
gentlemen th media podcast of course
like rate share review comment wherever
you watch or listen thank you so much
for being a part of our community and
we'll connect in a future episode